bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you're
subscribed to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account or
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
you can use the description right here
or you can go to blockfi.com
to learn more all right let's get in
this episode i hope you guys enjoy this
one
all right guys bang bang i've got
srivasan here with me thank you so much
for doing this
thank you so much for having me it's
awesome to be here for sure
uh before we get into the six most
legendary trades of all time
uh i want everyone to just know a little
bit more about you tell us a little bit
about your background
how old you are and what you spend your
day doing
so uh my name is shawatsen i'm 17 right
now so
i sort of got into the world of finance
at about 13 or 14. so it was basically
it was basically sort of an intersection
of my interest back then so i was really
interested in economics
i was also really interested in sort of
geopolitics and making money as well so
uh it sort of all intersected and you
know i started reading about it fasting
about warren buffett value infesting
which is sort of what i which is sort of
what i do so i spend
a lot of time looking at annual reports
looking at you know company numbers the
fundamentals and so on and so forth
and so that's sort of
how i got into finance and uh i saw
i also run a podcast called market
champions which i featured yuan
i don't know if you remember but i had
you on i believe about four or five
months ago
um so that was pretty cool and you know
yeah i feature all kinds of traders you
know people
who do equities people who lose their
currencies and whatnot
uh i spend basically most of my day
number one doing my
regular school stuff and then looking at
you know annual rewards interviewing
people
and you know so on and so forth so
that's sort of what i do
i love it uh i want to bring you on the
podcast because you
recently tweeted uh four of the most
legendary trades of all time and then
we're gonna add two more for uh for this
episode
uh but maybe let's just start with the
first one uh you said
george soros and the bank of england and
breaking the pound maybe tell us that
story real quick
absolutely so that's it's probably the
single most legendary trade of all time
uh pretty much you know everyone who
works on wall street
probably knows the story really well so
back then
and before now before this trade soros
was not actually very well known he's
that he was not as
well known as he is today so back then
there was this
exchange rate mechanism so what what it
basically did was it said that
you know the pound has to trade between
two point seven eight deutsche marks and
three point one three deutsche banks and
you know back then in germany
uh the currency was deutsche mark cannot
be general as it is today
and so after the reunification of
germany so when eastern
east germany and west germany you know
they reconciled and they reunited
uh the the german central bank raised
interest rates all the way up because
they were scared
that you know they're going to see a lot
of inflation and
at the same time the uk economy was
actually in recession
which means that the right policy in uh
the uk
would be to have lowering so that you
know it stimulates growth and whatnot
but but what ended up happening was the
bank of england
uh had to actually maintain by you know
this
this ban or this trading ban so that
because when you have lower interest
rates what happens is your currency goes
lower but you have higher interest rates
your currency was higher
and so since germany had really high
interest rates their currency was all
the way at the top
of the ban so it was rising against the
pound and so what soros thought was that
eventually britain would have to reduce
rates so that they're able to get out of
this recession and when they do reduce
rates
um britain would uh would eventually see
the pound fall
out of the exchange rate mechanism and
to add to this
number one uh the president of the
bundesban the german central bank said
that you know the pound
could come under pressure and could
possibly be devalued
so you know that sort of added to the
bearish sentiment another thing was that
the the chief of the boe at that time i
can't remember his name right now
but he said that he was going to spend
about 15 billion dollars
defending uh the great british bound and
defending this exchange rate mechanism
and soros thought to themselves hey
that's the exact amount of pounds that i
was going to sell so yes
himself wanted to sell about 15 billion
pounds
uh 15 billion dollars worth of pounds
so the person who actually found this
trade was
stanley druckenmiller who used to work
for soros at the time
and you know funny enough the story was
that you know stanley jackman had found
and he walks into soros's office and he
tells soros about it
and soros looks at him so uh you know
sort of so menacingly
you know stanley druckenmiller thought
that cyril was just about to rip apart
his entire decent and what ended up
happening was sora said that this was a
once in a lifetime bet
and while stanley chuck and miller had
about uh
one billion dollars worth of you know
position on it
doris told him he had to 10x that to 10
billion to 15 billion
and they spent a lot of time actually
just sitting there selling the pound
to whoever would buy it and
you know this was sort of a once in a
lifetime trade and you know you're able
to also see that
it's a very asymmetric trade so if i if
you know if stanley chucking
was wrong and you know the erm was able
to continue the maximum he would lose is
whatever the difference is in the ban
so it can go higher than whatever the
limit on the bank is so there's only a
maximum loss there
however the maximum profit was unlimited
because the
because the pound could just collapse
and you know it could get absolutely
destroyed
and in the and in the middle of
september 1992 when
i believe it's called black wednesday
happened um
everyone was just simply trying to sit
there selling pounds and there was a
there's another
extremely famous macro trader his name
was lewis bacon and on that day
he was able to find you know people sell
guys people to sell plants too
but then you know soros was unable to
find people to sell pounds too and you
know he was very very pissed off that
you know louis bacon was able to find
people to take the other side of the
tray but he was not
and you know that sort of and you know
eventually
the uk government and the central bank
realized that
they're trying to save uh the exchange
rate mechanism was
futile and and the currency would
eventually have to
be devalued so eventually they ended up
actually devaluing the currency and you
know that ended up
being one of the most legendary trades
of all time and soros ended up making
about one to one and a half billion
dollars in profit
absolutely insane right to not only find
the trade but also to kind of have the
courage to uh to act on it and do it in
size and conviction
which uh which takes you know what is a
a pretty good idea obviously
uh and makes it a great trade is because
of that courage and conviction they have
to act
another example of this is paul tudor
jones in 1987
uh he essentially predicted the crash of
1987 and was able to position himself to
profit very handsomely from it tell us
that story
okay so paul tutor jones as we all know
he's a very very famous trader
uh so actually in 1987 what he found out
that
was that the way the market was moving
was actually very very similar to what
was going on
in 1929 uh which was right before the
great depression he saw that the
correlations between
you know the way price was moving in
1987 versus that in 1929 was actually
you know very very close
and you know he did a lot of other kind
of data analysis so he sort of looked at
brokerage
reports he looked at ceo's data and
whatnot and he found out that
you know it was very similar when you
look at 1929 when you look at 1987
those two they were extremely similar
and about two weeks before
uh black monday happened in october 1987
uh they started to aggressively short
sell
the market he started taking this
position before anyone
you know realized that everything was
going to go bust
and so the cost is here is usually said
to be portfolio insurance so
basically what portfolio insurance does
it's sort of like a stop loss so it says
that if the market declines this much
no i'm gonna resell everything and so
there was a one week before black monday
the market was down about nine percent
and that sort of triggered every single
uh portfolio insurance model
and so everyone ended up selling uh
their stock and eventually on the monday
on black monday
uh the market fell about 22 or so and on
the friday before black monday
after the market closed uh soros
actually walked into stanley truck and
miller's office
now chuckie mullet tells the story to
jack schrager in the book the new market
wizard so
drakken miller who's actually very very
long so he had a long position
he uh he made money if you know
if the market went up realized that the
market was going to collapse
after seeing paul judy jones study and
on black one day actually in the morning
there wasn't much of a move it was kind
of flat-ish
so he was able to flip his position from
net long to nap short so he was able to
start he would he would make money if
you know prices started to collapse and
he ended up making a big profit on black
monday
but meanwhile you know george soros lost
the shirt um
because george soros was way too big to
you know to be able to flip this
position as quickly as stanley
truckenburger was able to
and you know uh paul peter jones paid
about a hundred million dollars from the
stray
and you know you can actually read a lot
more about this trade in sebastian
malibu spoke more money than god which
is
an excellent book about hedge funds and
there's also a documentary about this
that tends to you know surface from time
to time but you know
usually it's usually taken down
immediately but uh you know that's a
it's a very exciting documentation i've
watched it a couple of times i think you
know that's something everyone should
watch
yeah it's uh it's an incredible story
especially when you start to realize
that a lot of the uh
the legendary macro traders uh they
essentially were sharing the trades with
each other
right so uh not only was it uh
information that could be shared but two
was uh you had to be able to
act uh and be able to act within a
certain time frame
uh and with that conviction again and so
in that situation where george soros
uh was able to break the pounds but this
time he couldn't switch from uh from
long to short
ends up actually hurting him which is
very interesting
let's talk about uh the kiwi dollar
trade uh andy kreiger tell us that story
yep so uh andy kreiger was a trader at
bankers trust which used to be a bank
in new york but then eventually it you
know got bought out by
deutsche bank so you know typically
currency traders would take you know 20
million and 25 million that kind of
position but then andy kreiger who was
actually made
would take positions that were 10 x that
so about 200 250 million and on top of
that andy kreiger in general was
a very very successful trader and you
know his capital limit was about 700
million dollars
and so you know the new zealand dollar
was a relatively new currency
and what ended up happening was that the
new zealand dollar
rose about 40 against the us dollar from
1986 to
uh 1987. and so andy kreiger
analyzed it and figured out that the new
zealand dollar was extremely overvalued
and you know it was going to go down
and so when he when he actually showed
it it is uh he shorted it with a massive
amount of leverage so he used about 400
to one leverage that means that for
every dollar he put up he got to borrow
four hundred dollars from this broker
and
his shirt on the qb dollars was actually
much greater than the money supply of
new zealand so
which is which is pretty insane if you
think about it because it's greater than
the money supply so you basically
shorted more new zealand dollars
and there are new zealand dollars and
you know the finance minister
of new zealand actually called up andy
craig sponsor
it is claimed that he called up andy
craig's boss to say get the f
off our currency little effort uh and
you know krager
made a massive profit he made about 300
million dollars on this trade
and you know needless to say you know he
went and worked for george soros who's
pretty much the greatest currency trader
to ever exist so i think
so i think that's a pretty insane story
as well
it's incredible because it basically was
like a naked short to some degree
right where uh they were able to short
more than the outstanding
uh circulating uh currency and so when
you start to see this it's just
understanding the imperfections in the
market or the opportunities in the
market
and again courage and conviction to act
and and put the position on do it in
size
um and while you're risking capital if
you're right you end up capturing the
reward right and you know stanley
chucking will actually makes that point
in another interview where he says that
you know when he went to work for sorens
you know he thought that he would learn
you know what drives the euro what
drives the yen and what drives the
markets in you know russia
but you know but the only thing that he
really learned was that you know when
you know you're right
you're almost hundred percent sure for
sure that you're right then in nigeria
you should absolutely bet the house
on you know whatever bet it is so you
know for example soros was almost 100
sure that the brother you know the bank
of england would have to
uh pull the plan out of the exchange
rate mechanism so
he went in pretty much better but the
entire house he paid
10 billion dollars which is massive and
that's uh and you know that's sort of
the major lesson that stanley jacques
miller
learned when he was at sorrows for sure
uh the next story uh is david tepper
during the global financial crisis
uh and the big banks pretty much
everyone was
uh fairly concerned about the big banks
some of them had failed
uh there was a concern that there
there's gonna be like the
nationalization of banks but uh
david tepper stepped in and tell us this
story right so debbie tepper in general
is sort of a distressed kind of client
just just of investors so you know when
when companies are
distressed he tends to go and buy their
debt and buy their stocks especially
when their chances of recovery are quite
great and so when he's uh so
back in 2008 09 during the great
financial crisis everyone thought that
the banks would be nationalized just
like
they were during the great depression
but you know the officials had no
you know they had uh no reason to uh or
no intention
to actually nationalize the banks and
the government released a white paper
called the financial stability plan
and you know when tepper read that he
realized that the banks would have to be
saved
and so most people believed the us
government wouldn't nationalize the
banks but
no not temporary temporary thought that
they would not nationalize the banks
he thought that the banks would
eventually bounce back you know jaipur
was able to buy citigroup for about 79
cents
bank of america for about 372 or so um
though he was he was able to buy a
billion dollars worth of commercial you
know market-backed securities which had
pretty much
you know been the cause of been the
cause of the great financial crisis
at a ridiculously cheap price so he paid
nine cents on the dollar for every
dollar
of actual commercial mortgage-backed
securities and he paid only nine cents
for it
and he bought a lot of distressed debt
as well so he was able to find
you know companies that were distressed
companies that were you know on the
verge of bankruptcy
but and he bought a lot of their debt
and the
the entire trade made seven billion
dollars for his fund
appaloosa management and yeah pepper
personally he made about four billion
dollars and
you know in my thread i put that into
perspective so you know if kepper
actually worked 24 hours a day for 365
days that year
he would make 457 000 every single hour
that he works which is
absolutely insane because you know the
average american is probably not going
to make 450 seven thousand dollars in a
year
but he made it never in it yeah you know
he would make it in a single hour if you
if you put that into perspective so i
think
that's another extremely insane trade
that was made
it's unreal and david tepper is no uh no
stranger whatsoever to a distressed
situations and
and kind of fighting to uh to make sure
he drives in his profits
uh another example uh or great kind of
legendary trade is john paulson
with the credit default swaps tell us
that story absolutely
so uh as you all know that you know
michael lewis has written
a very famous book called the big short
where he talks about you know
steve weissman michael berry and jamie
mai who
also bought credit default swap so
credit default swaps are basically
insurance
against the collapse of these
mortgage-backed securities
and uh so basically if you buy if you
buy insurance you know you pay a small
premium but then you know when
uh [ __ ] hits the fan you get paid a
massive amount uh
a massive amount back so that so that
was sort of
that was sort of what these credit
default swaps are they're basically
insurance and john paulson
um realized that the the housing bubble
was spot to pop
and he went ahead and bought a ton of
these uh credit default swaps
on uh some of the worst mortgage-backed
securities and as we know in hindsight
a lot of the things that were actually
rated triple a you're not actually
triple a you know a lot of the
underlying mortgages in those triple-a
margin-backed securities for actual
actually garbage you know
actual rubbish um and so when
when you have when you have something
that's triple-a
yeah the the insurance on it is very
cheap because the risk
that they go under is very very low uh
so john paulson
was able to buy some extremely cheap uh
insurance on
uh these mortgage-backed securities and
he ended up netting about four billion
dollars for himself personally
you know this is documented in a great
book by itself called
the greatest raid ever by gregory
zuckerman which i think you know
all your listeners should read i think
that was a that was an absolutely insane
book so
and again it seems like the same uh same
thing you know same story which is
uh courage and conviction and doing it
in size really kind of benefited here
right
right exactly it sort of like you know
it's that sort of like the framework for
you know all these traits number one
uh it's usually a you know it's very
asymmetric and you know you you usually
make it in a lot of size
and you know you end up making a ton of
money from it
so uh so you know that's sort of what is
common
in all these trades for sure let's uh
wrap up with john
arnold uh and the natural gas trade of
2006.
so at the time amaranth advisors was
basically this multi-strategy fund
that had taken a lot of decency had
taken a lot of positions
in natural gas and um so the guy who
trades now who traded natural gas for
amaranth his name is brian hunter and he
was sort of on the
other side of john arnold's back so if
john
i know john arnold was long uh you know
brian hunter would be short and vice
versa and in general you know
in general these two traders pretty much
ran the natural gas market back then
so what ended up happening was that john
arnold um
so what ended up happening was that in
2006 brian hunter made some extremely
bad bets
and uh i'm not aware off the top of my
head whether he was long or short
uh but he made some extremely bad bets
um and
john arnold was on the other side of the
street of these trades at his
uh at his own hedge fund named centaurus
fund management
um he uh he took the other set of
defense and what ended up happening
was that amaranth advisors went under so
they had about
six billion dollars in management and
they were all dedicated to these bets on
natural gas
and none of these bets came good and you
know they ended up losing everything
and in 2006 the collapse of amaranth
advisors was the largest hedge fund
collapse
in history you know at that time so i
think that's right that's sort of what
makes the story insane number one
the scale of the collapse so it's the
largest hedge fund collapse number two
uh you know there's a there's pretty
much just one guy on the other side
who's making a lot of money off of this
so that was just john arnold who made
six billion dollars for his fun and he
made about three billion dollars for
himself as well if i remember correctly
there's a
good book on this called hedgehogs by
barbara dreyfuss i believe
that that documents this entire story as
well i think that was a that's another
intro that's another interesting
and exciting book that you know i think
everyone should read
um yeah you know a lot about these
stories how do you learn about all of
them like if somebody's at home and they
say hey i want to learn about
uh you know more of the greatest trades
in history
what would you suggest they do so you
know number one
it's usually i have sort of an obsession
with learning about finance so
uh so that's sort of where where that
comes from so where the
need for me to go and read about the
stories comes from and the second thing
is i think that there's a lot of
extremely cool books are written that
have been written
about you know about how these traits
work so for example
i mentioned a couple of them the
greatest straight ever hedgehogs and
one of the other books that uh that's
you know really worth reading is the
sebastian melody book more money than
god so
it's usually a combination of reading
being extremely curious and you know
if you read a lot you're going to
stumble on things that you know you know
you existed
because you're going to end up stumbling
on things that you never
uh you know that you want to go ahead
and research so for example
when i was researching about you know
how currencies work i stumbled on the
uh on soros breaking the bank of england
so then i went on to read a lot more
about it so i read pretty much
everything i could
you know all the stories especially
number one it's really interesting you
know
it's such a large amount of money that's
involved that's one thing that attracts
me to it
the other thing that the other thing is
you know i'm a huge fan of people like
stanley dracula
who who is one of the greatest investors
of all time so
um
yeah and you know if people want to read
more about them you could just you could
simply google them you could end up um
there you go you could read several
books about them i mentioned about three
books
um you know michael lewis is another uh
is another amazing author
uh and you know there was there was a
comment about michael lewis the other
day
uh that if michael lewis wrote a book
about the history of the stapler
i would read it and uh and i think you
know
that's what that's what makes michael
lewis so good he's a really really good
storyteller
and so the big show is an amazing book
liars poker is an amazing book you know
they're boy by michael lewis so
i think you know he's another awesome
guy that you should check out
yeah i i think that that is very very
true
uh what's the biggest takeaways that
you've had so you've done probably more
reading on finance than most people who
are you know two three times your age
what are the takeaways uh that you could
kind of just tell people hey after all
this reading here's you know two or
three things
uh that is just a repeating pattern in
every story
yeah so uh so one thing is that pretty
much every single you know
successful trader has simply avoided or
you know investor has simply avoided
things that they don't know a lot about
so they've pretty much stuck their
strategy they're stuck to what they know
they've been very very you know key on
cutting losses
and you know when you're wrong you just
get out of the trade as soon as you know
that you're wrong
and similarly you know cutting losses is
a key part
of you know being a successful investor
that's another thing that i've noticed
uh the third thing is you know they all
sort of have an obsession
with finance it sort of takes over your
life and you know that
that's something that you spend doing
you know that's that's something you
spend
uh most of your day doing so for example
warren buffett he said he spent some
motion today reading and reports and
and i think that's true for people like
soros and dragon baller and you know
paul jeter jones and
why not you know these successful
traders they have an obsession
with finance and it sort of takes over
their lives
they spend they spend a lot of time
doing it their friend's very invested
in uh you know in learning about
uh finance and you know i think that's
sort of that's sort of the hallmark of
what makes these people paid so they
stick to what they know
they cut uh they cut their losses
quickly and now they have an obsession
or a passion for it so i guess that was
the three main takeaways
yeah it's uh it's absolutely fascinating
how uh
the obsession turns into uh this thing
that drives them
uh to just find the trade almost feels
like in some weird way
uh it's not the money right it's not the
profit that's just the scoreboard
they're really just looking to uh
to understand what's that structural uh
mispricing
and then go and exploit it and then the
the profit merely just tells them yes
you were right in some weird way exactly
yeah
exactly you know yeah awesome uh well
listen i really appreciate you taking
the time to do this these stories are
amazing you'll have to come back and
tell us more uh in the future but where
can people find you on the internet
uh or where can they listen to your
podcast absolutely so
uh i've got a youtube channel so if you
just search up my name you know shabbat
and prakash
s-r-i-v-h-e-s-a-n and space
p-r-a-k-a-s-h
uh you know you can find my uh youtube
uh on twitter you can find me at elite
underscore investor
and then uh you know you can check out
my podcast you can just you know type
market champions into your search bar
and you'll probably find it
so yeah the uh the twitter handle
at elite underscore investor has got to
be one of my favorites that i've seen
out there so
uh i don't know why you chose that one
but that's a pretty good one
thank you awesome all right well listen
thank you so much for doing this street
watson and we'll have to do it again in
the future
absolutely thank you so much for having
me it's awesome speaking to you